raga ormai non so più che inventarvi per
fare le intro però dava amici tutto a
posto allora è stato un rientro
stressante perché sono rientrato dagli
stati uniti ho dovuto iniziare a fare
subito i video perché non avevo più da
parte infatti un giorno non è uscito un
video perché non ce la facevo proprio
come sono andate in vacanza ragazzi a me
benissimo a voi in realtà non ne frega
niente però ve lo chiedo che fa bello
allora parliamo di tante cose che sono
successe durante le vacanze in un altro
video non in questo son partito parlando
delle vacanze perché le vacanze hanno un
senso in questo video perché durante la
mia permanenza a new york sanjin
marchigiane c'è stato un giorno in
particolare dove variati migliaia di
messaggi in direct su instagram che mi
dicevano questa cosa mi dice
[Applauso]
si vede proprio che sono stato in
vacanza mi arrivano mille messaggi più o
meno dove mi dicono ora che bellezze
lewis hanno parlato di te in live
insomma in una storia non avevo capito
bene al momento quindi ho detto bechi
sai che khan detto sono andata a
controllare praticamente uscito fuori un
argomento che è stato generato dal video
che ho fatto
quanto guadagni quanto spendo perché
fedez ha detto questa cosa che vi metto
vedevamo il video fa vj dove diceva
quanto guadagno quanto spende quanto
guadagna quanto spendo e alla fine poi
non diceva nel controllo cioè diceva
quanto non spendeva e quindi dal mio
punto di vista mi sembrava un po
ostentare un miltare allora adesso voi
avete visto la storia quindi posso
rispondere del tecnico innanzitutto fa
ridere che c'era un sacco di gente che
mi scriveva insulti perché poi la gente
alla gente piace il dissing non vendere
magari uno dice a una famiglai ai
capelli marroni e fa vj e fede se ho
detto che fa vj capelli di merda perché
no ha detto che sono marroni che poi il
marrone si sa ancora della morte era
altro disco lasciamo non c'è non c'è il
sung issing perché vi inventate le cose
tranquilli primo secondo non vedo perche
nel senso che cosa gli ho fatto gli ha
fede
capitolini ora ho preso felici data come
esempio però questa questa cosa che ha
detto lui l'hanno detta tipo l'un
percento di tutti quelli che hanno visto
quel video era ragazzi io mi rendo conto
che i viola hanno visto un sacco di
persone e che quindi non possono essere
tutti d'accordo e va benissimo ognuno
deve avere il suo parere anzi sono
contento che si siano generate di gelati
dei dibattiti su questo discorso qua ma
adesso vi spiego donna risposta a fede
ma in realtà non tanto a lui ma a tutti
quelli che la pensano come lui perché
c'è una roba che gli è sfuggita in tutto
quel discorso allora per chi non avesse
visto quel video io dico che con tutti i
soldi che ho guadagnato a youtube non ho
mai speso niente quasi niente tipo non
mi vesto firmato se no non è con queste
magliette bellissimi ragazzi contratto
dal profilo frizione non mi piace
comprare roba firmata perché secondo me
è comprare una maglietta di gucci da 500
euro non la trovo una scelta giusta
perché per me quella maglietta non vale
500 euro questo era tutto il discorso
più o meno ci stanno facendo in quattro
partite ma tanto poi sarà tutto il
discorso più o meno che ho fatto in quel
video lino fedez dice che o stento
umiltà e secondo me questa cosa non è
vera per due motivi ma non è solo fede
scaletto questa corda cosa vuol dire che
o stento milita perché ostentare umiltà
vuol dire guarda ciò i soldi ma faccio
vedere che non li spendo così mi faccio
bello agli occhi della gente
che non spendo i soldi ma in realtà c'è
secondo me per due motivi questa cosa è
sbagliata per due non per uno il primo
io ho detto all'inizio del vitalizio di
quelli video io dico che non spende i
soldi perché un sacco di gente me lo
chiede cioè non è che me ne sono uscito
dal nulla dicendo ai non spendo i soldi
non è andata così un sacco di gente mi
ha chiesto ma lorenzo sa come mai tu
siccome guadagni i soldi soprattutto
dopo che è successo ad una roba di step
mi ripeto come ho detto nel titolo
perché tu che sei il primo in italia di
vesti come un barbone non avevano un
barbone ma non prendono messo niente di
firmato che la mia risposta è stata che
oggi e siete troppo abituati a vedere
spera e basta chiunque ma ne ha ma
chiunque vestì anche fedez che cito
anche tanto ma ha citato anche lui
vestirsi con maglie di supreme robe del
genere ma questa è un'abitudine che
hanno le persone perché oggi apparire
vuol dire tanto soprattutto quei social
far vedere che avessi firmato su
instagram ti fa apparire con un figo che
non so per quale motivo non lo so non
l'ho mai capito e mai lo capirò ma
l'essere umano è convinto che se vesti
una roba che costa 6 più importante non
è vero poi avere anche un vestito da 5
dollari ma essere bill gates infatti
bill gates che uno degli uomini che
richiamando si veste con le pezze come
me intanto si può permettere 85 yacht
però è uno stile di vita è un modo di
vedere le cose c'è nel senso non è una
questione di umiltà
innanzitutto perché io anche se ho i
soldi non li voglio dare a te i brand
tra virgolette che per me non se lo
meritano capito cioè se tu scrivi gucci
su una maglietta inutile o 500 euro
tenendo 20 se tu scrivi kakà profuso la
maglietta tiro sempre 20 perché c'è solo
una scritta su quella maglietta me ne
frega se c'è scritto ucciso cinque
lettere ad esempio adesso sono andato in
viaggio
un mezzo in america c'è mica se lo
possono permettere tutti qui non sono
umile voglio dire non è che me ne sto a
casa tutto il giorno
vado in america un mese a new york non
lo possono fare tutti specialmente non
spendo i soldi in quel modo fanno vuol
dire che io non faccio niente poi lascia
stare sottil chio quindi neanche quello
e poi non è neanche solo una questione
di come li spendi ma io in quel video lì
quando ho iniziato a parlare ho detto
ragazzi me lo chiedete in tanti vi
rispondo non me ne sono uscito io con
quel discorso mi hanno chiesto le
persone quindi non sto stentando sto
rispondendo alle domande cioè se uno mi
fa la domanda famiglie perché non ti
compri roba firmata il non posso
rispondere perché se rispondo osta in
tour il tarlo non ha senso me l'hanno
chiesto rispondo cioè quello il discorso
è capito quindi questa è la prima
risposta del secondo me il perché non è
una questione di ostentare umiltà la
seconda risposta del perché non c'entra
nulla sul meno ostentare umiltà deriva
dal fatto che secondo me i vestiti e
l'umiltà
siccome non centrano una sega l'uno con
l'altro ma quasi quasi completamente
nulla perché è uno che va in giro con
delle maglie di gucci non significa che
se la tira secondo me vi faccio un
esempio surreal power c'è lo sapete
tutti che suri si veste firmato nelle
foto su instagram si vede che c'è sempre
roba da 800 euro a pezzo addosso io
tutti i miei vestiti insieme non fanno
uno di suri vabbè però suri è una
persona umilissima cioè quando la gente
l'opera per strada si ferma far foto
chiacchierare c'è l'unità è un'altra
roba secondo me non c'entra nulla quei
vestiti
c'è uno può essere umilissimo e vestirsi
gucci perché ti piace avere quelle
cinque lettere stampate sul petto gucci
ti ti ti rende orgoglioso di te stesso
per qualche motivo che io non capisco ma
a te piace ciò che è veramente super
umile eppure si veste firmato cioè non
c'entra ostentare umiltà prescindere
perché sono nei vestiti sono come un
discorso diverso
l'umiltà e ogni seme di tantissimi
fattori non puoi metterla insieme solo
ai vestiti o solo sa quanto uno spende
in generale ci sono tante cose
il fatto che io ho costrinsi umiltà a
prescindere se come non funziona da
entrambe le parti perché 1 me l'hanno
chiesto e ho risposto quindi non ho
spento nulla secondo non c'entra tanto
coi vestiti secondo me l'umiltà è una
roba parte e poi ripeto veramente
secondo me vestire firmati non significa
tirar ovviamente più facile trovare uno
che si avesse firmato che se la tira che
trovare una persona tipo suri e si veste
firmato ed è umilissimo ovvio però non
necessariamente c'entra quello sto
dicendo poi aggiungiamoci fatto che sono
di ecco sono t o stento tirchiaggine con
umiltà vabbè lasciamo perdere per la
milionesima volta fate quello che volete
così soldi volete spendere 2 mila euro
per una maglietta che c'è scritto
supreme fatelo per oli aver concluso il
discorso non so se sono stato
confusionario spero di no
bella lì
[Musica]